one of the greatest fighters of all time
sitting to my right the founder of
Golden Boy Promotions the Golden Boy
himself whose guy Canelo Alvarez is
getting in the ring against triple G in
Las Vegas coming up this Saturday
good to see you Oscar De La Hoya thank
you sir thank you for having me kidding
me pleasure it's a pleasure I don't
think we've we've ever met before
no no first time first time but I come
round we have mutual friends and this is
I mean it's great yeah we're both
golfers well I mean I commit golf
I don't exactly play it go ahead you are
you art now but are you one of those
golfers that won't say you're
handicapped in public for fear of the
candy being given out you got to make
some money I'm retired Marshall Faulk
who I work with in the NFL Network pro
football running back here I will not
say his handicap on you oh yeah
Sandbagger so are you worse and bad no
no I like the golf golf to me is is a
game where it's probably one of the only
games where you you know the integrity
of the game you know that the honesty
and like I'm the type of golf for who if
my ball goes out to the right to the
woods yes and I have like rocks or
pebbles whatever behind it and if I move
a rock and the ball moves just a bit and
nobody saw yes it's like I'll give
myself a penalty you will yeah I would I
mean I I love the game of golf
but you know what that's a window into
your soul I believe I really do believe
that that if anybody decides to cheat in
golf without anybody around yeah how do
you look yourself in but that but that's
the great thing about golf you know it's
a yeah it's you mm-hmm and that ball you
know right now is that is that is that
now the fact that so what's what's a
what's a what's a game with less
cheating golf or boxing well I mean
that's why that's why I don't cheat in
in golf because I mean you know all
these other sports are so corrupt yeah
Jesus every sport out there like that's
going on oh my gosh except golf so again
it just shows you that you're still
moving around the ring yeah you still
haven't mentioned your handicap on the
air I'm uh I'm a legit for I'm a legit
for Oh
yeah index so which makes me wet like a
six maybe okay so item I can play a
little I can play a little Oscar two
little hairs got a stick over I play
lefty now you play left I play lefty
yeah why just picked up I one day I just
picked it up one day and I you know it
was happened to be a lefty club and
right just stuck with it well moving on
to corrupt sports that's a segue when
was the first time you saw Canelo
Alvarez when was the first time you laid
up um I laid eyes on him he was like 14
years old he was 14 years old and one of
his like trainers I was doing some
promotion in Arizona and he hands me
over a picture of this kid red hair
freckles I said oh well I mean this is
this this must be what is he Irish or
what is it no this is a Mexican kid that
I have that I'm training he's 14 years
old 13 years old and and by the way you
can that's your neck superstar and I'm
like okay yeah sure I mean I get all
these requests like all the time I see
pictures I see fighters and so ok sure
so sure enough I mean he turned 18 he
was ready to sign with a promoter and so
I already had started like noticing him
because he turned pro in Mexico when he
was 15 so he started making noise and
started knocking everybody out and so I
started thinking wow I have this
redheaded Mexican freckles good-looking
kid I mean there's something here that I
can do with him
I can promote him and and and sure
enough yeah he's now one of the biggest
stars in boxing today what took so long
you set this fight up do you think Oscar
um I think the fact that he had to build
up to the middleweight division mm-hmm
that's it because look I I was able to
jump six weight classes when I was
fighting yes and it takes time your body
has to adjust you know you have to you
have to build it up build up to the to
the weight class because the punches are
harder
you know I mean it's the guys are bigger
and faster and so yeah I was just
waiting for him to bulk up to the
middleweight division and here we are
now so he's ready so when it all comes
down to it here
how how how nervous do you get as a
promoter sitting there and not being
able to control cuz every great athlete
I know that no longer actually
physically competes but now is in some
form of either front office management
right or in the case of what we're doing
right now cannot handle not being in
Carroll you know I
so I'm sitting down right there ringside
watching the fight first of all I wish I
was up there you know second when they
start landing those big bombs I'm like
I'm glad I'm here right and so it's I
just want a great fight that's it when
you do all the work when from signing
the individual fighters to the actual
fight signing the contracts to getting
all the promotion in place all the
marketing and you're dealing with you
know everybody and their mother from you
know all the sponsors and the HBO and
this and that so you get all the work
done everything's running smooth it's
fight week we're in Vegas the final
press conference to weigh in so now it's
the fight Saturday night I'm just
thinking gosh I wish this fight would
just turn out to be like one of those
classics you know like like I really do
think this fight here's a Saturday night
Canelo triple G will be like Thomas
Hearns versus Marvelous Marvin Hagler it
was like three rounds of hell for both
guys you know I really do think this
fight here is gonna be even better than
that one Oscar De La Hoya here on the
Rich Eisen show so them how do you feel
I think I know the answer this question
but I'll ask it anyway
that a fight like Mayweather McGregor
gets so much attention right okay thrown
on it right every Priya purist that I
interviewed boxing pugilist purist
just scoffed at water a sideshow that
was right fact that that gets all that
attention and this fight doesn't get it
gates getting some attention it's got a
nice amount of attention but not even
close to what we were coming yeah well
we'll do incredible business on Saturday
night because it's it's obviously I call
it and people call it a real fight with
two boxers you know I'm no I mean
because yeah look mayweather who's a
boxer he's probably the one of the best
you know boxers in our generation goes
up against in an MMA fighter who has
zero experience in boxing what do you
expect you know it's like Mayweather
going into the UFC Octagon what are you
gonna expect you didn't expect
Mayweather to choke them out or to tap
them out or knock them out you expect
obviously McGregor to beat them in a
minute or two you know so this fight
here with Canelo and triple G it's a
real fight it's it's it's gonna be I'm
gonna call it like six to eight rounds
even maybe ten rounds of the hell for
both guys it's gonna be it's gonna be a
war so why do you think McGregor lasted
so long against me um I think I think
because Mayweather let him blast a few
rounds made it interesting for the
people to watch I really do feel that
way on money's worth situation given
them what absolutely I mean if he
knocked him out with in two rounds it'd
be like what do we pay the money for
well you well you know you know that you
know that Mayweather tried betting on
himself in the 10th round and the bookie
kind of you know told him look you can't
bet against yourself or with yourself
right in the 10th round so I mean that's
that's it's a true story
so you yeah I mean what here there mmm
right Oscar De La Hoya here on the Rich
Eisen show it has been 10 years since
you fought Mayweather it has been Wow
that 24/7 series yeah I was the first
one was a very first one incredible that
really was great yeah well you know you
people are still Tom I'm still talking
people people you know get to get to
know you you know who you really are you
know I mean yeah it's great you're the
fighter mmm you train hard you know they
can see you work out and this and that
but who are you like who
where do you come from like why do you
why'd you start boxing uh you know what
drives you 24/7 is pretty cool right and
and so the fact that Mayweather retired
but like where you could get another
shot it yeah
can I tell you the story on that please
so it's the story on that so the fight
was close you know I mean split cards it
was split cards I mean I do have to say
I was already go over the hill for that
one I mean there was not even close to
being on my prime but so I had a
contract a a rematch clause in the
contract for one year so what does
Mayweather do he retires for one year
and one day you know so there there goes
that contract and couldn't get the
rematch so why do you think he did that
Oscar well why do you think he didn't
want another piece of you is that what
you're saying of course of course that's
why not it was it was the biggest
generating you know money fight at the
time there's no question about it
exactly but that's what he's all about
is fighting for the money well the whole
thing though would be wouldn't a rematch
have been a bunch more money for him I'm
exactly so why wouldn't he have thought
I think the fight was too difficult for
him that's what I think that you would
have made life too difficult for you
wasn't wasn't his dad though your
trainer leading he was and and it's
funny because after the fight his dad
came up to me and said congratulations
you beat my son
yeah so what do you think then he fights
it it's a 40 year old and he retired no
he's doing he's great I mean he's doing
great he is like I said he's one of the
best boxers of our generation right now
and so but uh but yeah I think I think I
think his I think his legacy is going to
is going to be one where I mean look he
was being able to generate all this
money and he fought he fought for the
prize instead of fighting for the glory
and and you know and and and the actual
fight you know
no I'm saying sure I do I go ahead ask
him your quest
yeah groups Canelo's only losses to
Floyd Mayweather right how would Floyd
fare against this version of Canelo it
would be a totally different story
I mean Mayweather father Matt what 21
years of age and he had no experience
whatsoever although he did have tons of
fights under his belt but he didn't have
the championship experience that he has
now mm-hmm it would be a totally
different different different fight I
think but uh but yeah unfortunately we
won't see that rematch
well maybe you could well who would you
rather see your guy face Mayweather at
age 40 or McGregor right now I think I
would I would uh I would have them I
would I'm looking so forward to triple G
no I know right I mean I I just okay
there's nobody else out there I mean
because because this triple G fight yeah
this triple G fight is gonna be I mean
it's gonna be if you look all those
people that watched McGregor and
Mayweather were entertained yes where it
was it was uh you know it was it was a
it was they were entertained it was an
entertaining show or whatever it was
called yes so so and boxing boxing is
now exposed to millions and millions of
Peter it's true you know eyeballs but if
you thought that was a good fight and
this Saturday night I mean it's gonna be
it's gonna be a bloodbath it's gonna be
it's gonna be it's gonna be like see and
this is why I love the UFC I really do
because you go inside that Octagon and
nobody's dancing nobody's like boxing
and and and and just putting on like a
boring show it's it's a real fight you
know this is what boxing needs this
Saturday night is a real fight and then
we have that Saturday night triple G and
Canelo Alvarez in the t-mobile arena
Saturday this coming up and I'm I will
be my eyes will be peeled I will be
watching sir it'll be fun I will be out
there
before I let you go what is your
favorite boxing movie Cinderella Man
yeah why just the whole story about
fighting for the family you know for the
kids that era you know that era where
what was it a took place in the 40s 30s
40s I mean it's it was just such a
beautiful story I mean what he's what he
stood for you know I mean he fought for
what was right he fought for America he
fought for for his country for his
family uh you know the inspirational
story behind it of like you know you you
can be down but not out
you know mmm it's it's beautiful it's
beautiful so which which film that
you've seen looks like the real thing
like boxing like when you actually see
the scenes where a boxer in the ring you
raging raging bull that Raging Bull yeah
you have to also you cannot count out
Stallone you cannot count out the low I
mean which one which rocky well it has
the latest one with greed greed yes it
looked pretty good I mean hey it looks
pretty real I mean yeah he does a great
I mean there's a phenomenal job all
right
I thought you'd go with the one with
Dolph Lundgren you know with with triple
G come here on the Rich Eisen show for
the television audience we are going to
fight it out you and I you don't know
okay you know it's a look you just gave
me Wow don't worry we're not gonna
actually touch gloves figuratively
though okay that's gonna be that's what
we call a tease for the television
audience will describe it when the radio
audience returns Steve Mariucci will be
here in the middle of this hour to talk
about week one in the National Football
League and what he thinks is gonna
happen tonight and Monday Night Football
in both Minnesota and Denver and your
phone calls at 8:00 for for 200 for rich
here on this edition of the Rich Eisen
show I've got an idea for you Oscar
again because I'm trying to leave you in
a better spot than I found you
how about this okay the winner of the
fight just to give some sort of tip of
the cap if you will or just a bouquet
type hug okay has to go to
proflowers.com give the other a bouquet
of flowers I like that how about that I
love that 20% off I can give ever with
like let's say your guy of course Canelo
Alvarez wins we thought well what are we
talking about roses or petunias summer
rose bouquets or any okay of over twenty
nine dollars or more you can get 20% off
right now and you could use the code
Eisen
I like that check out I like that what
do you think Brockman beautiful may say
I'm sorry I beat you with a pro flower
why not they're guaranteed to stay fresh
for than seven days or your money back
which I've heard of guarantee about this
fight to get 20% off seller roses or any
other bouquet of $29 and more at
proflowers.com but use my code Eisen to
check out proflowers.com code Eisen it
check out don't wait to make someone's
day
[Music]
okay Oscar De La Hoya is spending one
more segment with us the HBO
pay-per-view fight between Canelo
Alvarez and triple G coming up in Las
Vegas on Saturday it's gonna be an
exciting fight I'm definitely gonna be
watching it I've always wanted to get in
the ring with somebody of your caliber
Oscar but I'm believing I'm more of a
lover than not a fighter so this is the
way I'd like to fight you if you don't
mind makes two of us okay here we go
oh okay all right let's move the okay
show mug over here won't have you ever
played this before you know what it's
actually my first time okay okay Wow
Oscar De La Hoya's never played Rock'em
Sock'em robots before Mike Canelo here
uh yeah and I'll be triple G just you on
the count do you have a belt that could
be I gotta bail okay ready here we go
[Applause]
contract Wow what's going on Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy